TO SICAL AND HAS
USE HIS SIZE INCLUDING LAST
THE LEAD.
>> Tripp: THEY BE THROUGH THE
NEUTRAL ZONE AND THEN HESTILL
ALIVE.
JUMPING INTO ING TO SHOOT IT WH
IT
>>
>> Mike: THEY WILL PLAY IT BACK
FOR BRADY SHEA HOCKEY GAME.
HE TRIES TO GET THE PUCK IN
DEEP AND SOME JUMP.
THE SHOT WAS TARGETED BUT BACK
HE FOUND HIMSELF ALL ALONE IN
FRONT OF ALEX TO 3-
1.
>> Tripp: HE SET UP A CHANCE
AND FLORIDA MADE A
SERGEI BOBROVSKY'S TOUGHEST
WORK OF THE NIGHT IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD IS IN FRONT THE
FIRST AT
>> Tripp:.COM P TO WIN THAT
DRAW AGAINST THE SECONDARY Y
HE CYCLES.TURNOVER.
THE PUCK WENT TO MacKENZIE
WEEGHIT BY NINO ON.
FACE-OFF COMING UP IN THE JOE
THORNTON.
STEVEN
MOMENT FOR ANDRDRWIN GET.
>> HTHE DRAW.
>> IT WILL BE
INTERCEPTED.
HE TRIES TO GET IT.